[Music]
we talked about the fact that you came
from d23 now a weekend later you're at
comic-con yes this is a to conventions
in a row for me but but two incredible
conventions I had never been to d23
before and I've but I've been to
Disneyland my whole life I grew up in
Southern California I'm a big business
web AK so that was that was super fun
well you're a Disney Prince but I told
you you're quickly becoming a king of
the con especially this place looks like
a Duke
it's a baron I don't know I've been
super blessed that you know Chuck
introduced me to this world I mean I've
read comics posters like video games my
whole life so this was always my tribe
but I never I was never a cosplayer I
wasn't I'm not really a big collector so
going to conventions wasn't really my
draw but then you know as Hollywood is
want to do it then slowly takes over
everything and so now
Hollywood is everywhere and then Chuck
got to be down here and then he rose and
four and you know and then doing nerd HQ
obviously my baby for six years is
definitely given us I don't know like a
really cool place in this community and
I'm really grateful for that even though
we're not doing it this year but I am
hosting Syfy's coverage of Comic Con
which is super fun well that you're
genuinely a fan like what do you geek
out the most especially this year at
comic-con um oh no I mean that the fans
really I I like I think exclusives and
reveals and all that stuff is super cool
but no man I just I I'm in the business
of bringing joy I hope I hope that I
hope that so much of what this is all
even about is that we're bringing joy to
these people who are the patrons of the
Arts who are the consumers who we only
get to do any of this because they
either say I like you or I like what you
do or I'm gonna buy a ticket to your
movie or I'm gonna watch your TV show so
that's yeah that's my business like I
just I just want to make people happy I
think you've been a part of and are part
of a lot of projects that have these
huge fandoms and of course after years
of playing Chuck now you're playing the
bad guy in the site yeah it was a fun
for you oh my god it was so much yeah
yeah I mean James III the whole kind of
path was I'm not dule years ago through
like NBC stuff
and and we just got along you know and
very kindred spirits and loved a good
dance party and then so we kind of
stayed in touch and then he was doing
psych and then I started doing nerd HQ
and then he was gracious enough to kind
of rally his troops at psyche like James
and Steve to come and do panels at HQ
and then I became friends with all of
them and they're just awesome just an
awesome group of people super talented
and and then they were trying to write
me into the show before it actually got
cancelled or you know ended there was a
musical episode I couldn't do that I was
doing Thor the dark world in London and
so then they came back to me you know
James I think in like I don't know like
February or March and he hits me up and
says hey are you are you free end of May
beginning of June and I was like for you
my friends anything well not anything
that's James Roday he's a dark man um
just twist it really inside but anyway
so he said hey we're doing a movie we're
doing a psych movie I would love for you
to play the bad guy
the look is based on David Bowie's then
what do gyarah I'm like dude you had me
a bad guy I'm like I'm so in and they
were they really gave me a lot of trust
and a lot of rain you know to go and
explore the space guys you know I
brought a lot of cowbell to the role and
it's and it's super fun man you worked
with so many amazing people in your
career of course Mandy Moore was among
them I mean what wouldn't we be
surprised to know about Mandy oh gosh I
don't know I mean she's just so like her
her level of music knowledge is
unbelievable like I love music I love
dance music particularly Mandy and I you
know she'll start talking about like her
lexicon like the things that she's
listening to I'm like what deep cut
where did you find that where she's
found all the Django Reinhardt's of our
generation and I don't know how you do
that you know he was hard enough to find
back when and so she's always talking to
me about music that I should be
listening to but I'm not and other than
that I don't know you know she's she's
like an incredibly strong incredibly
talented incredibly intelligent woman
who also like that is a little bashful
sometime but maybe just because she's
bashful when I'm around cuz I'm just um
I could just um I'm just like a bull in
a china shop I'm just kicking things
around and being loud balanced
Oh watching her on this is us I've
watched so here's the thing I got up to
like Episode four and then life took
over so I know there's a lot of crazy
stuff that happens it's all very
emotional I don't want the spoilers I'll
catch up on it